[Musique]
la situation épidémique actuel est
qualifié de situation grave grave parce
que les indicateurs sont un petit peu
tous au rouge
les leaders et à sont pratiquement
saturé les ni le nombre de malades aussi
vont-ils et est en constante
augmentation
sans compter des du nombre de malades
qui existe dans les services d'urgences
qui sont en attente de leader
[Musique]
bon
ça
la demande elle a augmenté quatre fois
par rapport à la demande
normal donc c'est clair qu'on dépend
d'eux au même temps de la production
locale ainsi que des emplois des
importations lors de la deuxième vague
on a on est allé rapidement importer les
volumes nécessaires à la demande des
deux pays européens de nos partenaires
en italie en france
mais pour cette troisième vague cette
piste là est très longue et donc on a
préféré importé de la voix algérienne
qui eux possèdent aussi des réserves
assez importante
[Musique]